opposers here's a fun fact about me
that's also my tinder bio I always win
at board games I win at board games so
much nobody will play with me
what can I say I guess people just hate
to see a guy like me succeed now my
strategy is simple I play smart some
might call it cheating but that's that's
just a word losers use to make
themselves feel better that's why I'm
mad as hell about a new edition of my
favorite board game that just makes it
harder for winners to win take a whiff
are you a monopoly cheater well the end
is newest version of the game is for you
Hasbro is releasing a cheaters edition
of the game later this year the idea
came after a survey revealed that over
half of Monopoly players had tried to
cheat during the game the new twist on
this beloved board game comes complete
with cheat cards of free properties and
even handcuff attached to the board to
keep those cheaters chained to jail
that's right they try to put you in
cuffs for a real estate crime and they
say this game is based in reality this
new tabletop abomination includes 15
cheat cards that actually tell players
how to play smart look these cards are
real there's identity theft that lets
you move another player's piece instead
of your own and squatters rule that lets
you collect rent from another player's
property Hasbro stopped giving away my
moves next you're gonna tell my son
Alito how I always destroy him at
Connect four it's easy I never taught
him how to count but this new cheaters
edition is clearly trying to handicap
natural winners by building our best
sneaky strategies into the game there
goes the neighborhood in fact there go
all the neighborhood's boardwalk Park
Place luxury tax question mark land all
of them
think about it if everybody's cheating
then nobody's cheating and cheating is
the entire foundation of monopoly it's
right there the origin story you guys
know this monopoly was invented in 1903
by Elizabeth McGee pictured here on a
counterfeit Dean now this proto
Elizabeth Warren created the game to
expose the evils of capitalism but
capitalism is flawless here's proof 30
years later an enterprising man stole
the idea for her game rebranded it and
got rich office and that's how you play
Monopoly do not pass go do not collect
any money for your idea I get to be the
car yay capitalism this cheaters edition
we'll do whatever it takes to hobble
winners it even has a tattle-tale
feature you report the cheater who's
near left to right to mr. monopoly via
facebook messenger and then he will
chime in to settle disputes and crack
down on rule breaking by handing out
consequences in real time that's right
monopoly has a special prosecutor now
what's next a district attorney for a
gumdrop Mountain a court stenographer
for Scrabble a building inspector for
Jenga sir look if you're gonna go in
there don't go in there but if you do
just tap on it with your index finger
first I suspected this cheaters monopoly
was part of a larger plot some said I
was paranoid but paranoid is just a
fancy word for always right so I did
some digging that's when I found an
article and hidden below the headline
were dozens of smaller headlines strung
together in sequential order it was
baffling but I eventually found a quote
there from a Hasbro executive admitting
that the new version will level the
playing field and make sure cheaters
don't have a special advantage level the
playing field no special advantage this
is not a drill socialism a large
it is time to focus up we could not let
socialism invade monopolies you can't
run an electric company from your spot
in the breadline this new cheaters
edition is simply unamerican in this
country we reward people who play smart
it's why billionaires get tax cuts why
Republicans control Congress and why
Merrick garland is currently bagging
groceries at a CVS somewhere there's
nothing wrong with playing smart just
listen to our president he didn't pay
any federal income tax so that makes me
sorry yeah it makes him smart you know
higher IQ needs to be for your
businesses to whether six bankruptcies
smarts but everywhere you look deep
state forces are making it harder to win
unfair and square check out Pennsylvania
where the state Supreme Court ruled
against partisan district maps
screw you Pennsylvania and we can't
sleep on Florida we're a devious federal
judge says they can't bar X felons from
voting
that's gerrymandering and voter
suppression two of our smartest place
it's only getting worse last week I got
maced in a wholefoods for sampling the
grapes come on people America is all
about plain smart it's who we are
we can't let some globalist boardgame or
state Supreme Court take that away from
us now if you'll excuse me I got a pass
go and collect I don't know let's say
$700
[Music]